[Music]
how are you i'm great man very nice to
see you
i've been fine i haven't seen you in a
while i think uh your life has changed a
lot since i say last you you have a new
wife a new bride oh you know what
actually i i i directed a kind of uh
and uh we had been married for about uh
uh two or three months at that point
okay okay but uh yeah kate and i got
married uh february of
2010. yeah 2011 20 2011.
you know what i've learned to do with my
wife never gets never get specific about
dates just like oh it has been all been
so joyous who can remember
um
how did you
how did you meet we met in uh in uh on a
flight to london actually and uh i did i
i've been reading there's been a lot of
postings lately about me and and my past
and things and i usually don't read them
but you know after thousands you bump
into them and uh
there was one comment i read and i know
you're not supposed to do that either
but uh i did want to clear this up it it
said something about how uh kate and i
had met and and then hooked up in london
and that she'd spent the night with me
you know you know a one night or
whatever well that's not true
we we kissed
that night and and that was it i said
good night after two hours
uh and uh we didn't
do anything much more than kiss actually
for several months i just wanted to
you know have that's free
very victorian of you as well i just i
just uh well you know she was worth the
wait yeah so now i would waiting that i
would think that would be difficult you
meet someone there's there's obviously
passion there and that that kind of
hadn't had sex for a decade it wasn't
that hard
you too uh yeah pretty good
i know what it's like
your wife is british is that right she's
from does she does she have a strong
accent it's not a strong accident but we
do say around the house that we're you
know two people separated by a common
language
yeah
just frightening she's hard to
understand certain phrases we were at a
restaurant a while back uh this is when
she was pregnant of course and so raw
egg is something that's you know a
concern for a pregnant mother and uh so
we were talking to the waiter and she
said excuse me do you have any raw egg
in it
is there any raw egg in it it's a bit of
her her own yeah regional so it comes
out as one it just comes out as rory one
word
that's what the waiter said he said roar
egg yeah what what is roar egg
viking worry
but yeah
but i finally said okay it's she means
raw egg
and i said oh raw egg i i don't know
have a bite and find out you are the
father of a baby girl uh
how baby girl faith baby girl faith is
eight weeks old now eight weeks old are
you changing diapers i do change diapers
i'm a good diaper changer
i have uh
a technique acquired over over several
decades um
my eldest is 28 i used to change her
diapers and
i i'm changing faith diapers
i have a quick sort of you know get it
off get it in get you know lift the baby
boom put it down wipe it off and put it
away
sorry about you know just dispose of the
problem as quickly as possible and cover
cover things back up
but uh wait i i mean i've been to you
look what do you mean you're just like
bang bang but pull it off put up toss it
and then that goes in the cannon and
boom the other one goes under and the
legs go up in here
but my wife however is much more um
[Music]
well she takes a lot more scrutiny with
it she's in there with a q-tip
that was good
and uh
she's not like well
honestly so we now
we refer to it sort of as baby torture
is the kid just
she's loses
she you will talk the baby
the baby gets impatient with it finally
yeah just put the diaper on but anyway
incredible
uh i prefer your method well